you look at a community that is in a
given habitat a natural question is to
say well has that community always been
that way has it always been there was
there a time where maybe there was no
life there and the answer is
well yes
the communities do change over time and
there is some initial period where there
might not be any life at in in that
habitat and then life slowly colonizes
it and the makeup of that life will
change over time the makeup of that
community and this general idea is
called ecological succession ecological
succession
and folks will often talk about the
different types of ecological succession
splitting it up into primary ecological
succession and so primary is when you
start with
no life
because you really have a new habitat
and then slowly life colonizes it and
the best example of that or one of the
best examples of that is when new land
forms due to lava flows these are
pictures from hawaii where new land is
forming as this lava hardens and at
first there is well when it's when it's
molten lava there's no life there then
it hardens and slowly
basic life or life in general will start
to colonize that that lava rock and some
of it you won't be able to see with your
naked eye it would be microbes and some
of it you could see it could be simple
ferns and and plants like that and these
are often called the pioneer species but
what they often do is make that
environment more suitable for other
types of life so they might slowly break
down that rock as they die along with
the broken down rock that also gets
eroded from the water in the air
and the rain it starts to make soil and
conditions more suitable for other types
of species and these pioneer species
they don't even have to just be plants
and microbes i was just reading an
article about how in hawaii uh humans
want to get that land because it's it's
it's beachfront property or the the
beach might have not formally formed in
the traditional sense but you have ocean
view property so humans might be some of
the first pioneer species who might want
to be out on that land and that new land
doesn't just form from lava flows there
are other examples of new habitats
forming so
right here
we have pictures of a new habitat
forming because of the retreat of
glaciers when the glaciers were covering
up these rocks you didn't have life on
them but as the glaciers as the glacier
retreats right over here you see things
like these mosses and other types of
pioneer species starting to colonize and
over time they're going to make it more
and more suitable for other types of
species so that's primary succession
another situation is when you have
secondary succession and there's many
different ways you could have sex
secondary succession one of the often
one of the most
one of the most cited examples is when
you have some type of a disaster
and so this right over here this is a
picture of a fire so we're here we're
talking about secondary
secondary
succession
where you had a community but then you
have a fire and so that fire might wipe
out a lot of the community and then it
creates space for other things to form
so after you have a fire the forest
might look something like this and then
notice you have more you have species
that start to colonize where a lot of
other species might have died or died
during the fire and sometimes after this
this
disaster of some kind you might you you
might get back to the same type of
community that you had before the
disaster but sometimes it could be a
completely different one that the
communities
don't don't
don't come about in the exactly the same
way so the general idea is communities
change over time we have ecological
succession there are times where there's
no community and then they come in
that's primary succession and then you
have times where you have disasters of
some kind that could change the
environment in some ways and it could
change the makeup of that community and
things don't have to be as dramatic as
new land formation because of lava or
because of forest fires or even
glaciers retreating it could be because
of a disease or it could just be because
a new
species gets gets introduced somehow
that changes the makeup changes the
competition the predatory uh the various
the symbiotic dynamics within that
community